one of our next presenters is the star
of Independence Day the number one
moneymaker this year was number one in
America number one in Europe number two
in Asia behind the Democratic National
Committee that was not a website joke
please welcome an Academy Award winner
in the star of the biggest box-office
hit of the year ladies and gentlemen
Tommy Lee Jones and Will Smith
hello mr. Smith good evening mr. Jones
we are going to bestow the awards for
documentary film two of them so let's
bestowing the best achievement in
documentary short subjects breaking down
the nominees breathing lessons the life
and work of Mark O'Brien
Jessica you cosmic voyage Marvin and
Bailey silly
Jeffrey Marvin and Bailey silly an essay
on Matisse Perry wolf special effects
Susanne Simpson and Ben Burtt
the Wild Bunch and album and montage
Paul say torn and Nick rent that's
what's up
you tell him what's in oh you get it and
the Oscar goes to breathing lessons the
life and work of Mark O'Brien Jeffy you
what a thrill you know you've entered
new territory when you realize that your
outfit cost more than your film do you
think I'm joking
this was a labor of love involving much
of both from some very wonderful people
sandy clothes from Pacific News Service
Shauna Hagen standard Singh low my
family the funders the good people at
real life and my dear husband Marc
Salzmann but my deepest thanks must go
to mark O'Brien
he's the gifted writer who's lived for
the past 41 years
paralyzed in an iron lung Marc hates to
be called brave or courageous because
he's never wanted to be seen as a hero
but more importantly as human being will
mark it was not your bravery but your
human humanity that earned this award
Cheers